if you thought Justice League was a mess
it's important to remember things could
have been far far worse back in 1997
Joel Schumacher's Batman and Robin and
nearly ruined comic book movies forever
but surprisingly enough it wasn't the
worst comic adaptation of that year
CBS took a shot on piloting a TV series
called Justice League of America but the
results made Batman and Robin that look
like The Dark Knight the premise was
simple in fact a little too simple it's
entered a Matthew settle as Green
Lantern alongside Kenny Johnston's the
flash john kassir as the atom and
michelle herd as fire these are all
characters that have been associated
with Justice League in the comics but
the kicker in this adaptation is that
they were all roommates and regular
people with ordinary problems
it's as if CBS asked for DC's
Superfriends meets NBC's friends what is
the matter with you in fact it'd be
shocking if that exact phrase didn't
come up during a pitch meeting Justice
League of America turns out to be a
weird amalgam of an action drama and a
sitcom except the special effects were
embarrassing even by 90 standards and
the comedy was downright painful that
were also extremely awkward interview
segments of the characters scattered
throughout giving the whole thing a
quasi mockumentary feel that interrupted
any semblance of flow it might have had
but a lot of the problems came from the
would be series botting the iconic
characters up there cause Green Lantern
was shown as a software salesman and was
based on guy gardner from the comics
while looking more at the kyle rayner
version and being as Dulles Hal Jordan
from the Superfriends cartoon if it's a
just you wanted to trust you'll get
meanwhile the flash was depicted as
struggling with unemployment despite a
SuperSpeed the Assam was a science
teacher who could shrink himself small
enough to fix an old school TV and fire
was a struggling actress who definitely
dressed up as a banana for a commercial
audition then there was Martian
Manhunter played by David Ogden Stiers
from mash whose face was always covered
with a budget version of what Jim Carrey
wore in the mask well though that might
all sound a little like some hokey
remake of The Incredibles
it wasn't it wasn't good enough each
character was unlikable in his or her
own way and the plot was even worse in
the episode the team recruits a new
member in ice who started out as a
meteorologist in the town of new Metro
yes that was the actual completely
uninspired name of a city from the show
after a freak lab accident gave White's
the ability to freeze things she worked
with the other heroes to take down the
villainous weatherman played by the late
great and Miguel Ferrer since the show
didn't get past the pilot it's not clear
if the plan was to feature a new villain
in each episode but for red there's a
serviceable job in one of his trademark
bad guy roles but even that wasn't
enough to redeem it the biggest problem
of Justice League of America was that it
couldn't figure out if it was a sitcom
or something more serious
while modern shows like arrow Supergirl
and Marvel's agents of shield find
subtle ways to use humour as a balance
for the darker moments this show went
way too far into family-friendly cheese
to ever make anything seem consequential
Justice League of America never hit the
air in the US although some overseas
markets may have seen it however the
pilot still has life thanks to the
wonders of the internet and the bootleg
screening shown at comic book
conventions but it's not a cult
following that's developed in the wake
of its modern availability it mostly
just serves as a cautionary tale about
half-heartedly adapting beloved comic
book characters when you have little to
no budget or creative vision
some people run away we were all into
different stuff two decades ago but it's
difficult to believe
anyone would have ever been into this
although Zack Snyder's Justice League
didn't do as well as expected at the
box-office and critics were certainly
not kind it looks like a legitimate
masterpiece compared to this show
Bastogne thanks for watching click the
loop icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know your love to
[Music]